to society yep
you can't just slide pass those lyrics
[Music]
Drake is now having to apologize to his
quote friends after referring to Kylie
Jenner as his sidepiece in an unreleased
song with future he also referenced
Kylie's big sister Kendall and and Gigi
Hadid on the same track on Wednesday
night the Canadian rapper was teasing
unreleased music on his Instagram live
that's when fans heard the inciting
lyrics and were quick to call him out
considering his friendly relationship
with the Kardashians and Kylie's
boyfriend Travis Scott the lyrics came
as a shock to listeners Thursday morning
Drake took to his Instagram story to
make it clear that being disrespectful
was not his intention saying quote a
song that Marc ran last night on night
owl' sound live said shouldn't have been
played it's a song that leaked three
years ago and got scrapped shortly after
he was just going too deep in the Drake
future catalog last thing I want to do
is wake up having any friends of mine
feeling disrespected so I just had to
say that to start the day back in
November rumors were swirling that Drake
and Kylie sparked a romance after her
brief split from Travis Scott it all
began after Kylie attended Drake's
33rd birthday party in October at the
time a source told et that the beauty
mogul and the rapper were not dating
fast Fords of February
the rumor officially died when Kylie
rekindled her relationship with Travis
Scott
[Music]